big day in the Consuelo's house
yesterday what happened Lola Consuelos
graduated college
[Applause]
[Music]
good job Mom Kelly Ripa and Mark
Consuelos celebrating daughter Lola's
NYU graduation but they're not the only
parents filling the Pomp and
Circumstance are you kidding me and
they're in college and they're doing
their their thing Kimora Lee Simmons his
eldest daughter Ming also earned an NYU
degree it makes me feel so proud Mark
and Kelly detailed Lola's big day online
it was such a gorgeous day it's at
Yankee Stadium
brother and sister there she is there's
Mikey uh
and I took a really cool photo of her in
front of Yankee there it is there's
Yankee Stadium and it was so funny I
made her get into the street and she's
like I'm going to get hit by a car I was
like yeah but this is a really good
phone Lola Brunton Center I know she's
always front and center Kelly shared
some behind the scenes of shots
including Lola and her friends her
graduation disco ball cake and Mark's
special sweatshirt with who else on it
Lola make up your mind to have
no regrets
recline yourself resign yourself
then afterwards we had a rager at the
Consuelo's house
20 whole 20 whole people
no all her friends and then um we had we
had some old friends also for Kimura and
her daughter Ming they celebrated
graduation day in style the 23 year old
rocking a white dress with her NYU
purple gown and matching hairstyles with
her mama my girls are alongside of me
whether we're working or playing seems
after the ceremony Kimora and Ming
hopped over to Cartier for some shopping
and champagne you're a proud mom to five
kids they're wonderful they're all
achieving you know milestones in their
respective age groups what is that one
thing that you're like we gotta make
sure that we avoid that I think my focus
is on them to be not too hard on
themselves
and to be happy
to be work on their happiness you know
if it makes you happy and it's not
hurting anybody else more power to you
as for what Lola's future holds after
college possibly a future in TV like her
parents but she might have some
competition with her brother if you had
one kid to take over or fill in for you
guys well one of you is away who would
it be would it be Lola Lola this would
be great Lola would be great but Michael
really wants the gig you know Michael
wins the game I think he says he wants
the gig because he's not done it but he
would be good at it so he's he's amazing
yeah no doubt both Kelly and Kimura will
lead their daughters in the right
direction congrats to Lola and me
[Music]